[موسيقى]
في السنوات الأخيرة ، سجلت دبي عددًا
من الأرقام القياسية العالمية من خلال
عروض الألعاب النارية المثيرة للإعجاب ، والآن تأخذ المدينة
عروضها الاحتفالية إلى مستوى جديد تمامًا
مع عرض الضوء الذي يضم أكثر من
500 طائرة بدون طيار نعتقد أن السماء هي
أكبر لوحة فنية موجودة هناك  من أجل
سرد القصص ، Sky Magic هي شركة تكنولوجيا طائرات بدون طيار
مقرها في المملكة المتحدة
وسنغافورة لأكثر من عقد من الزمان ، لقد قاموا
بإنشاء عروض متحركة ثلاثية الأبعاد
تضيء السماء في المدن في جميع أنحاء العالم
اليوم هم في دبي بتنسيق
أطول عرض للطائرات بدون طيار  في الشرق
الأوسط ، ترى نوعًا من الخروج من
العالم بعد الفحص ، ازدادت الشهية لعروض الطائرات بدون طيار
بشكل كبير ، مما جعل
كل هذا ينبض بالحياة ليس بالأمر السهل حيث
يستغرق الأمر عدة أشهر من الاستعدادات ،
نبدأ التخطيط في وقت مبكر من شهر يوليو.
قبل 10 أيام من العروض ،
نجري الاختبارات مقدمًا ، لذا نبدأ
بالتحليق بطائرة بدون طيار واحدة ثم الذهاب
إلى 20. أخيرًا قبل 3 أيام من
العرض الأول ، أسطول كامل  أكثر من 500
طائرة بدون طيار تصعد في الهواء
بعدة خطوات في تصميم
العرض المستقبلي
الممكن باستخدام
تقنية اللمس ، كل
ذلك مصمم خصيصًا لذلك برنامجنا الداخلي الذي
يستخدم أداة نمذجة ثلاثية الأبعاد ، ننتقل من
الصور الثابتة إلى
الرسوم المتحركة على الرغم من وجود عشرات الأشخاص.
شارك في الإنتاج عدد
قليل فقط من أفراد الطاقم الذين
يتحكمون فعليًا في العرض على الأرض
، نراجع جميع الحسابات القابلة للطي
مثل معلمات الأمان ، ثم نقوم بشكل
أساسي بتحميل ملف الرسوم المتحركة هذا
على أسطول الطائرات بدون طيار ثم سيقوم أسطول الطائرات بدون طيار بتحريك
تلك الرسوم المتحركة في  السماء
في الحياة الواقعية وفقًا لـ Sky Magic ، فإن
الطائرات بدون طيار المستخدمة في العرض أصغر
بكثير من طائرات التوصيل بدون طيار وهي مصممة
خصيصًا لتنزلق بسرعة
في الهواء وتغيير الألوان
وهي خفيفة الوزن للغاية وخفيفة الحركة للغاية
للتنقل عبر السماء وصفتنا الجديدة
بالإضافة إلى أنها أكثر مقاومة للرياح
ومقاومة للمطر ، فإن دقة نظام تحديد المواقع العالمي (GPS) عليها
قوية حقًا ، لذا فهي تجعلها
دقيقة حقًا عند y  أنت تحاول أن تجعل هذه
الصور الأنيقة بعيدًا عن
الطائرات بدون طيار الترفيهية تقدم بديلاً صديقًا للبيئة أكثر من
عروض الألعاب النارية التقليدية ،
والفائدة الرئيسية هي أنه
يمكن استخدام هذه الطائرات بدون طيار عدة مرات ،
وأعتقد أن المضي قدمًا في المزيد والمزيد من المدن في
جميع أنحاء العالم ستكون كذلك.  باستخدام الطائرات بدون طيار
بدلاً من الألعاب النارية هذا العام ،
يُقدر أن أكثر من نصف مليون
مشهد مذهل سوف يجتمعون في دبي
لمشاهدة الطائرات بدون طيار تضيء السماء
طوال موسم الأعياد حيث
نجلس بجانب المياه الزرقاء وقد
فاجأنا ذلك.
لقد انجرفت مع الموسيقى ،
والأضواء ، والجو بأكمله ، صمت الجميع نوعًا
ما ، لذا أحببته في
الوقت الحالي ، يستمتع المشاهدون
بتجربة فريدة من نوعها ، لكن هذه
العروض يمكن أن تصبح قريبًا القاعدة حيث
تستمر تكنولوجيا الطائرات بدون طيار في التطور
[موسيقى  ]
أجنبي